holy crap been in San Francisco for the
past week guys how you doing I missed
you I missed you I got videos coming to
you guys all weekend but first let's
review an epic Bible ish movie with
Russell Crowe should be its own genre
epic Bible this movie with Russell Crowe
how would that not be
no to NOAA stars Russell Crowe is
directed by Darren Aronofsky it's a
telling of the story of Noah ultimately
revised for a modern generation and in
Noah the world has gone to people
are shitty people are terrible they're
douchebags they're even the
land sucks you look around you're like
no one is family they're ultimately just
surviving this looks like they live on
Mount st. Helens the morning after so
Russell Crowe gets dreams of drowning
and death and he's like I'm gonna make a
leap here I think God's gonna wipe out
the earth I just that's what I think so
he gets to work building an arm this
droid from the Bible is pretty cut and
dry it's like knowing his family they
were good then they built an ark and a
flood happened and bad guys got wiped
out happily ever after this isn't really
like that definite license has been
taken for this story for what the Bible
story is and that's pissed a lot of
people off but this is my rule of thumb
if there's a movie that is a story from
the Bible and it's pissed off religious
people no disrespect to religious people
I'm saying that probably means the
story's a little more interesting than
you thought it was going to be I thought
the added context and the added things I
thought that was really good holy
Noah has these Rock soldiers from
Dimension X what so six are awesome
though these big rock dudes always
helping them build a boat yeah Noah is
hanging out with those rock transformers
from the 90s you remember those things
they turned into rocks not cars rocks
yeah they were pretty awesome at the
time and I like that what Darren
Aronofsky's done is he's made a world so
to put you in the world you're like I
get it I get how it was and how it has
become and why it needs to change no it
isn't a religious movie it's not it's a
telling of the story of Noah and Noah's
Ark and all that yeah sure I don't think
they're gonna be showing this in Sunday
school anytime soon they're just not
going to do they're not gonna be like
hey kids
here's Noah is sorry for the permanent
damage I just did to your mind because
it's pretty dark ultimately I question
like who are they trying to market this
movie after it's not meant for religious
people because clearly they're gonna be
like that is not the story it's
and Darren Aronofsky fans are used to
walking out of a movie of you're like Oh
what did it all mean let me think about
it for seven weeks it's a story and
Noah's Ark with liberties taken so it
makes it interesting and there are moral
grey moments with characters and that's
cool but you get it you do question
you're like what's Noah going crazier
was he just a really devoted guy but it
doesn't get any deeper than that it's
not like you walk out of this movie
going Orissa was she the tree or was she
not the tree this is like a good
introduction to Darren Aronofsky's
world if you're a Darren Aronofsky fan
and you have a friend you don't know is
it Darren Aronofsky fan no what would be
a pretty good movie to ease them into it
after that go ahead and show him requiem
for a dream and have him be like for an
entire day honestly I thought everyone
in this movie did a good job Russell
Crowe is great as Noah Jennifer Connelly
was great in the movie Ray Winstone
steps up and he's like he's a dick and
he was great in it Anthony Hopkins was
great in it her more than a few really
great camera moments I walked out of
this movie with one word in my mind I
was like that was epic which is also
interesting because it's about a guy who
builds a boat it was epic it was about
how the characters are dealing with it's
kind of like when you're watching
Walking Dead and in more than a few
episodes you're like there aren't a lot
of zombies but it's not about the
zombies is it it's about the people in
the end I thought Noah was absurdly good
at great camera work I had great setup
had a great world it created within the
movie great characters the stakes are
pretty high I mean this is the
eradication of mankind and shits that's
pretty high stakes religious people not
liking their Bible story mess with are
gonna be pissed off at the movie Darren
Aronofsky fans might walk out of the
movie being lucky I like my own auskey
movies being a little deeper than that
but I for one had a really great time in
the movie and I will say Noah is worth
buying on blu-ray right so Noah have you
seen it what did you think about it but
every thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you